eight years ago a pentagon committee
called the defense
science board issued a very stern
warning quote the cyber threat is
serious they wrote with potential
consequences similar in some ways to the
nuclear threat of the cold war
almost a decade later it doesn't seem
like the government is taking these
threats
as seriously as they promised they would
and suddenly those threats have
multiplied they appear to have
anyway when hackers shut down the gas
supply to the eastern seaboard earlier
this year for example the white house
said it was a private matter
and watch how joe biden's top
spokeswoman reacted yesterday to a hack
of about 250
000 servers operated by microsoft
microsoft says that hack came from china
here's how the white house responded
in march we heard from the national
security adviser jake sullivan he came
in here and told us that
the u.s in the near future to his you to
use his words
would name who's responsible for the
hack on the microsoft
exchange so can you tell us who that is
most of several months
have passed and what the hold up might
be i'm happy to check with our national
security team to see if they have an
update
as you know they are quite careful and
thorough i should say
thorough is probably the right word and
how they review and assess and provide
public guidance but we can see if
there's anything more they can report
out
is the prevailing theory still that it's
china or can you not go any further than
he did
i don't think i have an update on it
from what we've provided in the past
the white house also is not commenting
on news today that hackers with ties to
china
tried to hack new york subway system in
april of this year
but the interesting thing is that not
all hacks get this treatment see if you
can spot the difference when
another country is involved watch
president biden certainly thinks that
president putin and the russian
government has a role to play in
stopping and preventing these attacks
hence it's a it will be a topic of
discussion when they meet in two weeks
what's going on here exactly sincere
question glenn greenwald has a theory
about it he's an independent journalist
he joins us tonight glenn this seems
like
a potentially crippling problem these
cyber attacks
were utterly dependent on the internet
you could shut us down with a keystroke
the responses from official washington
are puzzling what do you make of them
it's obviously bizarre in the sense that
we're constantly talking about
our massive defense budget we spend 10
times more on
defense than the next 12 countries
combined it is run through the
department of defense constantly this
word is invoked to justify
these huge bureaucracies and these huge
military budgets of
we have to defend the country and yet
when you look at the defense budget
very little of it is actually about
defense things like protecting our
industries and our
food supply and our energy supply from
actual hacks right that spending money
to fortify those systems that would be
defense there's very little of it
that's spent on that and you see this
over and over you know when i did the
snowden reporting
in 2013 which was about eight years ago
which is when that report came out
75 billion dollars was spent on the
intelligence budget almost all was spent
on spying on american citizens hacking
into the systems of other countries
virtually none was spent on how to do
defense defending our own country and
even during russia gate when there was
all that hysteria about the russians
hacking our election system people like
tulsi gabbard a democratic congresswoman
would say if you're really that worried
about it pass this bill
to provide paper ballots to make sure
there can't be hacking and there was no
interest in that it seems like sometimes
there's a real
interest in hyping this enemy constantly
creating new programs and bureaucracies
that
take billions of dollars but simple
solutions to actually provide defense
don't generate much interest in
washington
that's such a great point about paper
ballots and
people just weren't interested i vaguely
remember this people were not very
interested actually in protecting
the system with paper ballots which
would do it
yeah i mean that's what was her point
you know tulsi gabbard would always say
all you do is hear about russian
interference in our election russian
hacking of our election system
there's a really simple solution i have
a like a two paragraph bill
that just requires states to generate
paper ballot back up so that nobody can
ever hack our voting machines because
we'll have a paper backup to prove it
and i think she had like four sponsors
in all of congress
while they were constantly babbling
about russian interference in our
elections and it just shows you that so
often these things are pretext to
build massive budgets that really have
nothing to do with the interest of the
american people
it's totally and exactly right and your
point about our food supply is ominous
and true
the country's biggest beef supplier was
just taken down with a cyber attack the
other day glenn greenwald i appreciate
you coming on tonight thank you
good to be with you talker thanks hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else